me I can hear you we're surrounded by
dog all the time
page boundaries why are you in my pants
welcome back to the jury before we
started
Alina's sorry okay I've wanted animals
in my lap yeah you know what I did
before this podcast started what'd you
do I sneezed while I was peeing how did
that go
I don't like other green eyes how did
that happen you know that's always like
way peeing you like think it might
happen like you get all tickly in your
nose and then it doesn't you were
actually going in it it really happened
so it was horrifying did you get it
everywhere see you don't know if I'm
talking about the pier the sneeze no no
neither got everywhere but it was the
weirdest thing ever you didn't hear me
from the bathroom I went achoo ah no I
didn't do that oh that's it happen
probably that I was one of the dogs
yelling about nothing when you're like
keen you've never sneezed while you peed
oh I have but it's much more terrifying
for a man why did it go everywhere wine
what did it go everywhere I can't
remember the specific incident but I
know that it's not a fun feeling
especially if you're in a public
bathroom nice knees yeah normally what
you do is you pee a little bit on your
hands when that happens did you also
poop your pants
yeah and I threw oh my god like the
worst [ __ ] body reaction thing
happening ever yeah
you peed and sneeze and pooped and threw
up at the same
and that's a good time that's what I
like to call a party ill so many fluids
and solids oh and semi solids God and
gases and everything in between right
Peach Luigi she's been really cute
yeah we started to train her she's being
really good she's super smart she
actually like it helps so much having
permit because she'll watch Kermit do a
trick and then just sort of do it yeah
she picks her up at fast but then she
also has an attention span of like what
is she have it she has an attention span
of a fly that has an attention span of a
gnat she's still really little so she
can only pay a touch of her solo she is
little and she pees every third thing me
on there she's not even that little
she's almost as big as Kermit I think
she's gonna be bigger than Carli massive
she'll be like she's gonna [ __ ] dwarf
Kermit I know she's almost as tall as in
yeah Kermit's gonna be a baby compared
to her she's gonna be a mom you're gonna
be that's unladylike to be so big you're
gonna dwarf the man what's wrong with
that what she can be big and strong what
if she wants to be Xena Warrior Princess
I'm excited for her to be a baller like
a giant beast like that taking after her
daddy she's not gonna be a beast she's a
beast
she's gonna be like the full size great
I wish it was so sweet though you'll
never be a B I know I'm kidding no it's
really funny though because right now I
can picture her as a goofy small dog
that doesn't even have control her own
body but soon you know in a couple
months or you know a year whatever she's
gonna be bigger than Kermit wait till
she's goofy and big it's ridiculous and
they never get undue fee yeah you gotta
lean in the air a little echo going on I
know I had an ankle but I've so many
things on my lap in it maybe we get so
close yes see there you go that's all
okay isn't that better yeah that's
better
you just got to turn up so it gets it
real well but you gotta turn you make up
so it is your voice really well geez
your voice really well well well well
well well would you rather have a
permanent microphone attached to you so
everyone heard you really loud or have
every fart that you do um have like a
birthday um like you can you like also
when you fight you like explode some
confetti and any parts it's a great
happy birthday but it could still smell
like a fart and I just cut out zone too
loud yeah just I don't know turn it down
a little they gotta find that middle
ground
um so answer my question please I think
I'd rather have a fart birthday party
because that sounds really funny a fart
bird no it's like forever every single
far is it good I got it
that's what I want okay then have a
microphone in my face all day every day
it wouldn't be a physical microphone it
would literally just be like your voice
is amplified all the time so ya know I
like the idea like imagine a lady
it is Starbucks you're like waiting in
lines all quiet everyone's tired it's
early and you're like hey kind of a
[ __ ] couple shots of espresso no no I
want to have a fart birthday party
people really the [ __ ] I'd rather be
standing in line in Starbucks and then
all of a sudden it's like happy birthday
like a Betty and balloons and rainbows
in a cake and then people are like oh
what a fun oh god what is the worst
party ever
I think it'd be really awful and
inappropriate that happened like at a
Funeral Oh Jen Rome
so too far which would you rather have
no now you ask me you're on you put your
mouth God what was that what would you
what but but but okay Julian would you
rather have toenails that never stop
growing or fingernails that never stop
growing toenails dude but what about you
should I go like I skate on them you ill
ill how do you figure this bullet rolls
down and he's gone hmm
another skis yeah that's disgusting how
would you lift weights though I would
take up speed skating and I wouldn't
wear skates I don't think they allow
that technology sir sir sir Sir sir you
can't be on the ice with your long
toenails sorta nominees nail clipper
please leave
you need a nail saw Oh Nell saw band
name called a nail saw oh my god do you
know it's really bad though when people
like they bro their nails out for the
Guinness World Record and [ __ ] like that
that you know I'm dying yeah I won't do
that as a kid I was always so baffled
why people did that well the nerve
starts growing like down the nail bed
farther and farther and farther like out
from your hand so if you ever really did
want to cut it you matter it would start
to hurt like depending where you cut it
that sounds fun hey what are you doing
with your life I don't know just making
it painful to cut my nails forever I
just like like forever the record hold
it like there's always that crazy white
trash lady in America that's doing it
the best she can but the people that
actually hold the records are always
just like in the middle of India just
standing there with like their weird-ass
[ __ ] hand and the curly like nails so
creepy you creep it what are they doing
over there they can afford to just give
up one of their hands I do not know I
don't know they're growing their finger
they're probably eating a lot of what do
you eat to grow your now I don't like
oils and fats they're eating oils and
fats you know
do you think they cut off part of their
nails and then make it into an oil and
then it's nail oil and then you coat
your nails with nail oil that seems so
[ __ ] up that seems like mad cow
disease you grind up some cows and feed
it to some cows and so you grind up your
nails and feed it to your nails that's
how they grow so long here nails yeah
I'm here little Meili they have mad nail
disease they grow your nails grow nails
so then usually cactus on your hand get
nails some nails oh this is disgusting
ask me a new one it's like in Family Guy
episode when they all get superpowers an
egg they're like hey Meg would you do
rap she's like I can grow and retract
right nails yeah what what I said you
asked me one now oh um would you rather
every single time you honk your car like
even if it was like a reflex like you
just saw someone cut you off Pam would
you rather every time you did that a
small man would magically appear on the
roof of your car and just start playing
really really bad piano like really loud
but you couldn't knock him off who's
there like for good would you rather
that or would you rather be that small
man I'd rather believe this moment and
then I really thought that my day huh
that seems like a great gig yeah small
man gig is a good gig he I think he goes
to Vegas sometimes you guys should check
them out I think it's on small mancom
well that's like some weird [ __ ] for
you is that everyone I've never visited
small mancom don't don't hold me is it
small man or small men plural Smallman
it's Mormon plurals maman swagger asking
boys small man it's mama
that's a that's a me and Mark that's
what we call people who are like shorter
or smaller than average people but
really act it you know I mean like some
people are small and they they have just
such out like a loud annoying in your
face shitty personality that you
like all that guy's a smallman like he's
trying so hard to not look small that
he's being smaller he's a small man
mm-hmm plug in Napoleon complex
yeah it's what we accept it's worse
because you walk around thinking you're
you know look I guess it is in the plain
complex but it's just like a modern-day
one like people with suits all the time
and there's food yeah me smallman are
sewing like like obviously some people
need to wear suits to go to work during
the day
if you certainly do not mean to be
wearing soup from [ __ ] 7:00 a.m. to
11 p.m. or yeah right on the weekends
when you see these people it all just
came from work I just have a happy hour
dude it's Sunday at 4:00 it's not happy
hours that you get out of your suit go
home hate that like even like the times
what I really needed to get dressed up
for work there's been plenty of times
like the second that I get home or have
an opportunity to go home I can't get my
clothes off fast enough you don't I mean
like if I'm wearing real pants and like
habit sorry like what you know what I
mean yeah like I just cannot get out of
my work clothes ah forget it when when I
yeah I mean when you bar attended and
you know even if you're just wearing
jeans in a t-shirt you get home and
you're just like oh give me my underwear
and get my socks on like I don't want to
wear any clothes it's just like the long
grind like you never want to stay in
your work clothes I think it's
definitely like look at me I'm in a suit
kind of thing yeah but like I'm just
talking about like a like a formal ish
day where is so uncomfortable by the end
of the day that it just baffles me that
anyone's like I think I'm just gonna
[ __ ] eat dinner in this like I'm what
you have to be [ __ ] drunk like yeah I
can't when people just suit on I think
people just become so numb to how
uncomfortable it is because they were
every day of their life like people who
work 9:00 to 5:00 and have to wear ties
and stuff you wear it more than you wear
anything else you wear it more than you
sleep email you know
like you you literally living in that in
that suit so like when when you come
home it's like yeah yeah I could take it
off and Mike and we're comfortable with
the same day at the same time like I I
was blobs molded in this suit like I
don't care it never I could never but I
also just don't like the air of people
that are like that when you're out like
at a bar something you get there at
nighttime and you see people in their
suits that have clearly been there since
like five three exactly and bro go home
how's it close huh come on and how is it
that those guys are always the ones
getting sloppy drunk being [ __ ] all
the time how do they get up and go to
work in the morning oh you're alcoholics
they know how to do it oh god it's dark
it's dark back - would you rather would
you rather um meet Rihanna but
accidentally accidentally call her
Beyonce or never be Rihanna
I'd rather exhale Ecology's I've done
that before not not like a celebrity or
anything they call Rihanna beyond yeah
you know I do it no but like when you
when you call someone the wrong name and
then you're maybe like oh my god I'm so
sorry I'm really sorry
[ __ ] no you can you can you could make
it graceful what is one name that people
have mistaken you for the most like you
told him your name's Jenna but then
they're like hey Jamie
like what is that name that that would
happen if you were to tally up that
amount of times that would win in your
life
Oh Mia I mean I've gotten a bunch of
them have gotten like Jonah and Gemma
like with M's like really like that's a
really common gema gema really uh but
probably Jonah Jonah okay like hi my
name is Jenna they're like okay Jonah
okay it's not even like they mistook it
for another name oh they're just made
one up yeah that's not real I get Justin
you get Justin yeah I mean for some
reason like people associate the fact
that I have Ju
you and then when they forget my name
they're like I'll chain you
oh it's Justin yeah I mean they don't
think Julian Ju so I think that's why
because they're both Ju names think of
another guy Jane you name I can't
Justin Julia there's Jonathan that's Jo
James J a Jo Luke
Shahrukh so you can give me a droop joke
his girlfriend name is tisha so you
gonna be my girl fair enough
don't slow look away me mm-hmm John Luke
mm-hmm Joe Luke is on fire someone
should go help him
fobba-liscious rhyme really Justin
though Justin I got called it today oh
god you Justin coach your coach coach
James a million people in the rope knows
yesterday knows Thursday he was like
Justin I was like Julian and he was like
oh my god
Julian sorry oh my god yeah I was really
funny because we're me and Rome we're
just talking about this daily date I
work with Rome and she used to work for
Neil Young the artist musical artists
and he called her Ron for three years
Rome Ron and like everyone else that she
worked with was like no don't correct
him he just he I just your name is
Rhonda him and so she was like I'm a
thousand percent sure if I like what
after he was like hey it's wrong like
how you been like I got nothing
yeah the thing is wrong if anything's
wrong that's amazing
yeah but she gets all kinds of cuz Rome
is an unusual name but then she US as an
Australian accents yes so it sounds even
weirder it's like yeah they think she's
thinking all right guys get off too many
dogs there teait right she said arm
somebody thought some people call her
arms we will call her Ron sorry
gonna be a lot of movement and I drove
because the dogs got off me now they're
just gonna sit there and cry so I'm
ready for that in Parks and Recreation
there's character Jerry that I won't
just shits on all the time and his name
actually is Gary but when he joined he
was afraid to tell everyone so he just
went with Jerry
so he's like someone asked him like he
was like what's your real name he was
like Gary and then something carry your
names like Gary it's Jerry just had a
stroke or something no that's actually
my name she's never told anyone
um the baseball coach at my college
his name was Carrie McConnell like CA
gar why hmm so raychel the one that
lives in Germany my friend the one we
weren't me and this girl Rachel we're
not allowed to like room together on
trips like we weren't really allowed to
ride in the band together like we needed
to be separated as much as possible
because it was too much [ __ ] for
everyone else yeah and then you see it
very angry at us for doing nothing but
laughing but I'm like hey you're doing
nothing that's doing being serious yeah
you can get out of my face with that
[ __ ] get the hell out but so the coaches
name was Carrie McConnell it just slowly
digressed into I'm gonna go to coach
Gary's up you meet oh uh is coach Gary's
office good to coach Barry's office
damn it watch how the hell you can god
you know I think coach areas are [ __ ]
uniforms tralala
that's awesome girl I'm Harry McConnell
that's amazing but I like when you take
someone's name and you turn it into
another name and then casually call them
that to someone else that's yes that's
really funny
no we used to give everyone nicknames
too I'm a baseball team especially do
they know what their negative memory I
don't think so but like we would come up
with such fantastic ones and then it got
to the point where we only knew them by
those names and then you don't hear
what's a long week
like let it slip like at a party or
whatever and they make what watchers
call me this I think was the best ones
we came up with there's this huge kid
named Nick I think it was Nick I
remember but he used to like mashed
bombs I was just sad eh they would throw
him in when they wanted them to [ __ ]
crush but then he would just [ __ ] around
on the bench and just like sing country
songs and like jizz whatever but he
looked very bizarre but he's huge
they look bizarre in the face so we call
him sloth like from the Goonies and so
we be like oh me and you hang out slot
last night and you're like yeah dude
sloth this bugging so funny he was like
wasted beings like falling down and then
you know one of the kids on the baseball
team was like push sloth
we got a deuce nobody stole him and
don't worry about it don't worry about a
guy but that's the kid with the the
ponytail centerfielder we used to call
him obliques he had long hair and he was
tan and he didn't know that he didn't
say much no good nickname did you ever
do that with girls you never made open a
theme for other girls
yeah when like with a group of friends
were together and one of the girls
dumped one of the friends would call her
[ __ ] you know we had like code names or
anything um sometimes I don't I can't
uh-huh I want to see non-systematic is
that that's right
I mean we we really just picked a
nickname that you know we could all
remember who we were talking about
it wasn't like meant to be mean yeah did
I ever [ __ ] tell you that I had a
strength and conditioning coach in high
school whose name was Kermit no you
didn't I haven't told you that No well
that's a thing
what who's what human besides Kermit
Washington is named Kermit
his name's Kermit what how can anyone
take him serious he's jacked black dude
and
that's why what I you could be named
anything and be giant jabbed and you
like okay all right yep you can't my
name is Kurt you are who what's your
name oh never mind you yeah that's cool
um yeah he was huge he was Jeff actually
was really small Kermit Kermit small
inject its mommy he was like probably
five foot seven but just shredded to the
bone and he also had like a high voice
like a Kermit voice how did he condition
anybody like that he made friends with
everyone but I think he probably had it
rough when he was a kid if that was his
name when he was a kid it's probably got
so shredded that's what I think happened
I think he actually told us that one
time Oh Kermit I liked him I would
always stay after and get extra workout
in did you from Kermit yeah he was da
man he liked me too because I like
worked hard and yeah we like he took us
to the way from he took us to the Greek
we had like a Greek theater in high
school I was just giant Greek theater
and you have to run up and down
miserable so I can you doing Greeks
today it's like yeah [ __ ] hate Greece oh
one time we were doing Greeks and we did
this thing where so we had a bunch of
variations sometimes you run up them
sometimes you would hop up them or
sprint or whatever and sometimes you do
spider crawls down them which is a
language like shoulder workout so you're
like on your hands and knees spider
crawling down these huge these steps are
like two feet each they're giant steps
and so that sucks right you're doing
spider crawls okay
and let me just this story is sad so
we're doing spider crawls and um I'm not
ready my body's not ready so we go to
the field right once we're headed to the
field we know whether we're on the field
or we're in the conditioning you know
area for the day so we're dressed
appropriately so that day we were just
in shorts and t-shirt with sneakers on
because we knew we were going with a
great yeah um what I didn't know is a
friend of mine at the time Logan his
name was logan not the one you met this
viennese news tall
his name's Logan Richard she's cool kid
I like him but he was always such like
such a [ __ ] prankster he would like
[ __ ] with everyone and anyone and he
like gave no Fox and he was always just
kind of like having a good time but he
was oddly like one of the most talented
guys on the team because that's just how
it works out so we're leaving the locker
room I got my stuff for it ready and it
just so happens that that day I had for
the first time ever worn these brand new
sneakers to school like these nice like
Nike they were called Nike ESPYs they
were skateboarder shoes and they were
called the Heineken one so they had like
green nike swoosh and a red star like a
Heineken but they were fake you know I
mean the real ones cost thousands of
cause I got knockoffs but they were
still really cool so I warned the school
that tales like yeah check out my Nikes
peace so I put them you know on my
locker you could lock your lockers
sometimes so my backpack longer and I
got my baseball shoes on ran out there
and we run the Greek's we do the spider
crawls and everyone's shoes are just
getting torn up doing these spider
crawls down because your shoes dragged
the whole time but I'm like Arthur my
crappy sneakers whatever we get back to
the field and we're like breaking for
the day and I look around and I see
Logan and I see he's wearing my brand
new Nike ESPYs and they're destroyed and
I was like are you kidding me those are
not my shoes and he was like yeah they
are it was like a giant joke I was like
oh man that's such a funny [ __ ] joke
you [ __ ] I was so sad did he get you
new shoes remember what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] is right if my mother bought me
are you watching Logan I love you my
mother bought me new [ __ ] shoes and I
told her that happened she would have
gone to school and punch a kid in the
[ __ ] face I'm pretty sure he I mean
we were friends like we hung out
together it's just like it wasn't funny
dude I was like son Frank there's plenty
people on YouTube that don't know the
difference between a prank and like half
of you two it's not a prank
how come a [ __ ] stories memory that
was just awful
yeah it's about as tasteful well yeah
because the the
the point of a prank is that people are
supposed to laugh at the end and not
always like an audience member like
ideally the person that you just pranked
would laugh you know there's nothing to
laugh at there hmm it's just me yeah I
was sad I really loved I was just like I
don't know he did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that was funny but that was just like
damn I love those she that sucks
yeah but uh that can't suck he doesn't
suck he's going home somebody wrecks his
new [ __ ] shoes it was a rough yeah
it's a rough day
I don't know why I told that all story
but there you go there's my sad story
about my shoes you know who racked
something new of mine one time a dog
Ichi I had a boyfriend a long time ago
in college and he had a dog a puppy
named itchy who he couldn't really take
care of so I was taking care of HP for a
year and this dog was terrible and used
to like chew everything ever like ripped
the curtains off of my wall like bit the
rod in half like just a [ __ ] he was
so stressed out that like obviously I'm
in college I can't be there and he was
older than me and had a job and then
didn't have a job but still can have the
dog and I'm like I'm doing my best here
man but it's your dog and he's just
destroying everything like you gotta
like pick him up and figure out a way
for him we spend some time was more
people he's just getting sad he wasn't
getting enough exercise you mean um but
other than that other than if that was
like three days a week he was like super
stress and then the rescue is okay yeah
but so for my 21st birthday I bought
myself a pair of brand new jeans which I
never do ever ever ever like I don't
even know any jeans now yeah I was like
so excited I was gonna buy his expensive
[ __ ] pair of jeans there are seven
jeans over like a hundred dollars when I
was like 21 years old was like oh
there's so much
hey I'm gonna use them and love them
forever and ever and ever like you save
up yeah I was like this is my birthday
present to myself and I went out for my
21st birthday in my new jeans and my
brother was there like oh so much fun
and then I wake up the next morning and
itchy had chewed that pair of jeans to
shreds that one pair of jeans and
nothing else it's like he was like oh do
you guys have fun last night because I
stayed in the house and I'm miserable oh
my god no
remember how I'm always like oh like
yeah peach to South Korea chew stuff but
in the grand scheme of like your dog
chewing your belongings it's pretty
mellow
it is pretty no although when you walk
into living room it looks like a bomb
went off because she chews out all the
stuffing out of everything but you're
right like I haven't had I'm even in
there though for her but it's for anyone
that has a puppy that loves to take
stuffing out of things if you have a
pillow that they love to taste like I've
these those cheap brown pillows that
I've had forever she liked it was Kermit
actually when he was a puppy got that
little seam open so that he could rip
this stuffing out and then every day
when I come home and I find it and just
stuff it back in because they want to
destroy things so if you give them the
same thing to destroy over and over
brilliant I know right everyone Joe's an
ode in the comments of everything you
just did you miss change did you slug
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys I'm like it's a
technique it's keeping my shoes intact
like I'm [ __ ] that all the cords are
gonna be okay no it's really smartphone
it's it's like keeping them busy because
you know they're gonna go after it well
because they I feel like the Italian
grounds love like soft toys yeah so
they're either going to destroy a new
toy and then the couch and then whatever
they want yeah or they'll just destroy
the same thing over
over there not at school and smart I'm
cool with the mess it is a mess
we're outsmarting these act little dumb
dogs you so dumb this is the same pillow
don't you know yeah she has I mean uh
she chewed a one of the cords for these
so we had to get a replacement cord but
other than that there hasn't been any
like serious you know casualties yeah I
think Hermitude a lot of my makeup
brushes yeah Oh peach choose my makeup
makeup brushes too all the time
[ __ ] you know because I didn't have
anywhere to keep him in Boston yeah so
when I was doing a makeup everything had
to be on the floor while I was doing it
because this the sink was just the sink
and so like he would just come in and
because some of them are real animal
fire he's like super duper duper
attracted to because all the good
brushes are [ __ ] real fur than the
synthetic ones for us yeah exactly
that's how it always ends out so they're
expensive oh yeah so there you you buy
them thinking that you're making a like
because if you take care of your brushes
well I know you're just like yeah [ __ ]
whatever [ __ ] if you take care of
your makeup brush as well they should
last you a lifetime some of them the
bigger ones the better ones um but so
you know my younger self is like I'm
gonna save up my money and buy this like
one brush no and then Kermit will be
like oh man is this new like when what
is this like what smells so good and got
me such a nice treat mom I think he got
like one or two of them really good with
the bristles but most of her most of
them he I would catch him with it in his
mouth and I feel like it's like he would
try and do this he's like slinky yeah
see oh it's always so funny when you
catch them in that yeah I was sitting on
a toilet today this morning and I'm just
like you know just just take it you know
taking it easy in the morning and the
toilet paper roll we hadn't changed yet
because we just switched it so it was on
the ground like a foot away from me and
I'm like sitting there on my phone and
Peach comes in and she's like hi hi oh
my god and then I'm like yeah whatever I
like and then she just grabs the toilet
paper and leaves
oh my god like you did that on purpose
Kermit when he was a baby he I've seen
him do it when he was an adult aside
from the weird baby wipe thing that he
used to yeah are still with us yeah when
he was a baby he used to just do the
same thing followed me into the bathroom
be like yeah we're in the bathroom is so
exciting turn to the toilet paper roll
which of my old bathroom was like just
slightly out of reach for some [ __ ]
reason yeah and he would just go like
put his little arms up and it was like
the most fun game ever to unravel it
with his little [ __ ] hands and then
he would get the end of it and run out
of the bathroom little devil if you're
in there brushing your teeth he would go
in there go minging and get the end and
bolt such [ __ ] yeah toilet paper
cooking yourself it could be a lot could
be worse but it's so annoying yeah
dammit dammit Kermit you annoy us and
then you're so cute we can't be mad at
you I know if I don't I don't think that
marbles obviously chew nothing yeah he's
never chewed anything like chooses food
heat when I got him you know like when I
get a puppy you get them like little
toys they're like little stuff for them
to have like a cute little belonging
there and they stayed brand-new until
Kermit got got born no like he didn't
even chew on them I swear when he was
teething he just like sucked it up and
just like stood there he was really
funny no little baby marbles so he's so
teeny and little he's lip hell he's so
laid down he's late tail
he's lip yeah I should cross your
fingers that she doesn't get anything
crazy but imagine having like a gigantic
dog yeah I do stuff they chew some yeah
I've seen our videos and pictures of
people's living rooms and you're just
like oh my god yeah that's your life the
damage
they can do is very very scary but yeah
today she went into my closet all the
way upstairs into my closet grab some
shoes and then brought them all
downstairs so that happened I mean
nothing that she does so far knock on
wood is like seriously like [ __ ] can't
believe you did that it's all just like
really small annoying things that you
can fix that you can you know replace or
whatever but she just does it in a way
is she so naughty
she is very really naughty but um she
loves so many tricks though in the last
couple days yeah and Jenna's been
helping me train which is amazing
because I like kept frustrated but
Jenna's like you know she knows she you
should watch her train the dogs so I
should like vlog at some time she's
really good she's just like you like sit
there and you know exactly how their
temperament is gonna go like for each
when you're training her you're like
okay no don't get mad at her just like
wait until she comes back she's gonna
come back here I mean and and just kind
of keep drilling it and then when she
makes a hint of the right thing you just
really praise her but it's been going
really well like peach knows sits you
know stay she knows coming or yeah and
then she's learning she knows pretty
well like high five she's excited lay
down lay down and speak today chuletas
he's she's doing all those which is good
it's also good cuz when Kermit like she
comes next - Kermit she just kind of
looks at what he does and just doesn't
yeah she also knows shake - she knows
shake she does she's a real boxer man
she uses her hands to dress but like I
said earlier today when I was teaching
her speech I was like this was kind of
the last trick that you want to teach
them because they're like it's their
default for whenever they're not getting
with you know start winding yes so good
so you're like all right lay down like
[ __ ] high five but if they're if they
don't do it they just go but boys blew
it
yes I yeah yeah yeah
look up oh you wake up go back to sleep
that's like hermit like if he's doing
tricks and you're like carpet rollover
he doesn't watch music kind of
excellence pathetic cry Oh telly around
there funny does so funny it was a funny
useful funny you're funny girl she's
really funny girl Petey goose Petey
goose sorry we had to put this up so
late um we still have all the madness
going on kinda really yeah that's like
what's happening um you know hopefully
we can get back to doing it Friday
nights and hopefully we can do you
stream sometimes also Helene oh yeah
seriously I mean we just keep getting so
thrown off because we unfortunately
still have so many things to do in terms
of moving like that house is not ready
every free second that we had today and
have had has gone into just like doing
stuff and then you gotta get your work
done and do what you got to do and I
feel like my schedules been slim yeah
you've been pretty much every single day
doing something and then on top of that
we've had to both tackle household
things huh but you know well every day
I'm doing something
- Wednesdays and Thursdays but every
other day from that I'm doing like other
people's projects yeah yeah I'm like
[ __ ] I need a [ __ ] can I got your
second to upload some [ __ ] to my blog
channel but uh yeah it's been intense
and then we'd be up super early tomorrow
don't forget yeah we have to be up early
um and we do have some good vlogs going
her channel coming in the hall so I'll
make sure I'll stay on her so you guys
can see that too much help me okay we'll
be back next Monday hopefully we'll be
streaming a little sooner but we love
you
Friday Halloween that's right as always
BuChE BuChE BuChE uh so yeah we public
16 Friday night but we love you guys
yeah thanks for watching thanks for
watching and comment all of the things
below like what your goofy little dog
does lit held on and what names you came
up with for groups of people when you
are concealed and what people called you
what it wasn't your name and what was
the meanest think someone did to your
new shoes yeah go war go podcast Dan and
we'll see you guys next week